you made a point right now about the
fact that uh you know if it wasn't for
him maybe Trump doesn't become a
president and you're absolutely right
indirectly well look in the thing is
like in an election as close as the 2016
election was any one major factor you
know kind of is the difference so you
know that was certainly a major factor I
just can't get past look man that this
guy was sexting with a an underage girl
totally humiliated his family publicly
and then the idea that he's just like
morally lecturing you that you had the
nerve to bring up the fact that it like
a ridiculous amount of people very close
to the clintons have died and like but
you're just not allowed to bring you
didn't say the clintons have murdered
these people you went hey what's up with
this and just like the moral like
condescending to you as if this was some
outrageous offense like what we're not
allowed to even think of the possibility
that maybe probably politicians have
people murdered like now who's being
naive okay you know like that famous
line from The Godfather look these
people the clintons these are people who
we all know have had people murdered in
Mass numbers we just call that foreign
policy we just call that when they
decide we're going to go on a bombing
campaign and Iraq as Bill Clinton did
throughout both of his uh terms had a
massive blockade around Iraq where the
U.N estimated 500 000 children starve to
death okay that this was the un's
estimates I'm not sure if they're right
or not but the idea that people who do
that for a living would be so
uncomfortable also off the clock being
like yeah I'm okay with this guy being
killed is not that wild of a jump to me
and if you want to do a deep dive into
it I'm not going to go full Alex Jones
here but there's a lot of very
suspicious deaths around the clintons
and it's totally fair to bring that up
yeah it's it's by the way I will say
have you seen this documentary or no the
documentary called winner yes I did I
did see it I did I forgot about it I did
it's the documentary of his comeback
when I watch it originally I thought it
starts in a weird way here's a
documentary winner last night I get home
uh uh Vinnie where's Vinnie Vinnie you
told me to watch if any somewhere around
here yeah he said Pat you may want to
watch his document or I get home at
midnight from here and I sit down and
I'm like I watch half of it I watch the
other half in the morning next thing you
know an hour and a half later I'm
finishing the whole thing it feels like
five minutes what they did during that
campaign with him and his wife everybody
has to watch because the one area you
got to give him credit this guy was an
incredible campaigner and if there's one
quality that he has that's very hard uh
for most people to have and you almost
need this because
obviously you know if you can get away
with you know the texting side set that
texting part aside and you just kind of
flirt and set the under the 18 side he's
a super competitive psychopath
competitor like many of these other guys
but
the guy is Shameless and there was an
element of being Shameless and
Relentless that he was not gonna let the
right after the second story comes out
he says babe there's a scene you guys
will see this right there's like so
you're gonna get in the video or what we
got to make a campaign video it says
a story just came out that you just
texted a 50. do you want to get here in
this video or not we need to make a
campaign video
do you understand what I just said
there's a there's one point if you
remember I actually forgot about this
documentary but I did watch it there's
one point it was one of those amazing
things I've ever seen in a documentary
if you remember right at the end when
the whole thing is just collapsing for
them
everything's going down and is
collapsing in the polls and it's clearly
not happening and the the guy behind the
camera he's in this moment where he's
just so down and the guy behind the
camera actually asks him he goes why are
you letting us do this like why are you
letting us record this moment and he's
just like
oh we asked them the question today Adam
I think you asked them the question
today what was his answer to you he says
I said have you seen it since I've never
seen the documentary and it's how come
you've never seen it he says for an
opportunity one day in an interview like
this to tell you I've never seen it
that's about why haven't you so why'd
you even let people why'd you do it what
was the purpose of doing it he says I
don't know so people can kind of see
what the story was like behind closed
doors you know but when we asked him the
question I said so what do you think
about Hillary Clinton you know honorable
honest people very honorable very honest
great people etc etc this guy literally
sounded like a full-blown flat carrier
and the word that came out I don't want
to speculate anything but I'll tell you
the word that came out of my mind and
this award I got to give credit to this
war to I believe Vinnie if I'm not
mistaken
you ever heard what A a dead man switch
is
can you pull up the definition of a dead
man's switch a dead man's switch okay
okay pull it up Zoom it in so we can
read this Adam if you can't move your
feet I can't see it uh uh a as a switch
that is designed to be activated or
deactivated if a human operator go a
little bit to the right human operator
becomes incapisated in incapacitated and
capacitated such as through death loss
or loss of consciousness or being bodily
removed from control originally applied
originally applied to switches on a
vehicle so meaning if
because he knows everything I said
Anthony you know you know
you know you know
there was a moment it's like I'm saying
I know for a fact you know what nobody
here I don't know anything and he's
looking at me like you know how are you
alive
how are you alive the only way you can
be alive is because of this
where they fear if they do something
that maybe like this is going to come
out and something's going to Trigger
story being emailed to everybody in
media and they're going to be like holy
[__] so that is the only way I can in my
mind justify why he's alive why he
builds them up why they protect each
other and why the other people are
sitting there saying let's leave this
guy alone now obviously all of this is
speculation yeah no one knows if there's
credibility behind it or not but it's
worth speculating well I think that like
what one of the things that we kind of
learned from the whole Jeffrey Epstein
uh Scandal is that there are at least in
this one major like uh example there are
these attempts to like gather blackmail
on very powerful people and this is part
of the reason why really [__] up
people rise to the top because people
who are say like if you're say texting
with an underage girl and someone has
information about that they now can
control you completely that's what the
whole Jeffrey Epstein thing was
essentially he'd invite these powerful
people out to parties they'd be like
there's parties there's tons of chicks
there'd be there'd be cameras in every
room you go there you hook up with one
of the chicks the next day Jeffrey
Epstein goes by the way she was 15. and
also you're going to be voting no on
this legislation that's coming across
your debts next week like that was
essentially there's there's some
speculation whether he was working for
the CIA or Mossad or who he was working
for exactly but that basically the
operation my guess would be someone like
Anthony Weiner there's people we may
know some of the dirt on him but who
knows how much dirt all of these people
have on him so he may be very required
to when Hillary Clinton comes up you go
to bat defending what a noble person she
is or else you know what's crazy Pat
that that blows my mind that
so many people are oblivious to this how
much back-end crap goes on whether it's
blackmailing each other like for example
you think about like the clintons for
example you're thinking about these
powerful people they've been in power
like to a normal everyday person like
you and me you don't think about killing
somebody because you don't have a lot to
lose you don't have anything to lose you
lose a job you'll get your next one you
know you lose whatever you you know your
company fails you're only making two
three hundred thousand dollars a year
you go start another company but when
you're in power for so many years at the
highest level of your life and you're
making this much money and that chair
that you have makes you so much money
you'll do anything to keep it so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]